trevor williams on the hill 2-2 now
got him and he went back to it and
struck him out
great start for trevor williams
fred anderson on the mound and wrigley
as we head to the bottom of the first
half swing roller there to make the play
hero nice and easy start from brad
anderson one
two three the cubs go in order we head
to the second
brewers coming to bed
swinging a miss strike three trevor
williams
fooling urias who did not take one of
his better swings
that is strikeout number two for trevor
williams
with the pitcher at the plate 2-2
pitch and down he goes anderson with a
strikeout
his first these two pitchers are
painting
moving through three innings here comes
the one-two offering
fly ball right center on the run chris
bryant and he makes the catch
that line drive and in right rod i
always think about a ball
might be tough to see looking up into
one of the light standards but chris
after hesitating ever so slightly was
able to locate it and run over and make
the backhand grab
fourth starters and they're dealing swag
and a miss hira
down on strikes and trevor williams
continues to be on point that's his
third
strikeout the one-two strike three call
yellets caught looking off speed pitch
got him
strikeout number four for trevor
williams so lead off man aboard
first base runner for either team and
here is wilson contreras
swinging a ball rick centerfield bradley
going back
[Music]
first 10 of the year and it's a biggie
wilson contreras a two run blast to
center and the cubs jump out front two
nothing
never mind a hit and run hitting trot
is looking for his first home run of the
season
and now the 3-2 on the way swung on hit
in the air deep right center back goes
garcia
and that ball is gone javier baez with
his first home run of the year
opposite field and the cubs now lead by
a score of
three to nothing home runs by both
contreras
and baez here in the fourth inning
against
brett anderson here's a drive out
towards left
center field forget about that
following baez three homers
in the inning just an amazing
turn of events here this pitchers gain
pitcher dominate a game
all of a sudden has turned into an
ambush by the cubs
one two for williams swag and a miss
struck him
out he has struck out three in a row and
five in the game the o2
and that's on the outside corner four
straight
williams is struck out six in the game
two away here in the fin
[Applause]
and how about trevor williams first
start in a cubs uniform and he's perfect
for
five cubs lead at 4-0 here comes the 3-2
to narvius
ground ball fair down the third base
line it's a base hit
and the brewers have their first base
hit and base runner of the game
duffy was well off the line the fans
they'll give williams
a standing ovation
trevor's father is here i believe those
are a couple of
relatives along with his dad yes dad
richard they
think they were fired up watching them
throw five innings a
no hit baseball and now they're loaded
and now things start to get a little
dangerous but one two
get on the ground at third can they turn
it there's one
yes they can 5-4-3
exactly what williams was looking for
[Applause]
it's sharply through base hit just past
a diving duffy and the brewers get
something cooking here in the seventh
inning now
a walk in a single two on nobody out
and decision time for david ross
and that may be one of the reasons why
he said trevor back out there trying to
stay away from kimbrell
and squeeze as much as possible out of
his starter
85 pitches david ross takes the baseball
and listening you know rich
trent and tanner loving it great
job trevor williams cubs lead four
nothing first start as a cub
has broke up the perfect game led off to
six with a single
there's a swing and a drive into right
field hit well
and narvaez sends it out of here
three-run home run
omar narvaez with a hot bath
just like that the brewers are right
back in it
it's a one-run game as narvaez hits his
first clout
of the season got the right guy up there
right soulguard
against a guy who generates so much
swing and miss soul guard's a good
contact hitter and delivers
that one lined and base hit it rolling
towards the corner run in
delivers against his former team he's
not stopping
and a third rbi triple eric
sogart long is nothing for two also hit
by a pitch
swings and misses strike three a
vanishing slider
and that's out number one
now good slider as you said pat by
chaffin and the key
is getting ahead in the count right the
o2 is swinging to miss strike three
sometimes they can't back-to-back
strikeouts for andrew chaffin
yellett strikes out swinging on a
curveball
andrew chafin strikes out the side
mill's ready to work to ureas
1-2
ball game cubs win
and welcome to the williams family
trevor in a cup uniform dad and his
brother's in the house
he gets the win 5-3
the final and the power supply delivered
in the fourth
[Applause]